older brother's two years older than me
so i i was i was kind of small and short
and
he was already very well developed and
very hairy i remember
when he showed me his pieces that like
almost almost fainted i was like oh my
god
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast
i am your host your roast coming queen
a girl who ate lunch in the theater's
prop room and thought that made her
better than other people elise morales
and with us today we have our very
first duo guest episode
uh they are dudes they are bros
they are activists and hosts of the
going
deep podcast right here on the all
things comedy network you know that miss
chad goes deep but before
all of that they were graduates of the
hotchkiss school and jay
sarah high school it's chad kroger and
jt park
honored very honored i read that you two
met in high school is that true yeah
uh we met doing a beer bong actually
remember at one point uh one of our
buddies said he's gonna make a
quesadilla which
like yeah as he probably knows was gonna
kill the party because he was just like
all right
just like he was like i'm just gonna go
make food and crash and we're like
and so in an effort to save the rager i
uh went out
and got my mount chug more which is a
four hose beer bong beautiful
uh now yeah i was gonna chug with kellen
reece and landon
um but i believe it was rhys
jt was it reese's cut no i think it was
kellen was on antibiotics yeah kel on
and back so
he had to sub out and then jt subbed in
and that's when we first met just
chugging and
uh did like your eyes meet was it like
it was the hand clap it was the hand
clap afterwards and did you feel
like okay this is going to be my boy
yeah it was like yeah what's her name
golding the singer golding
ella golden ellie golden ellie golden
yes
she has that song with major laser
powerful and since when you touch me
it's so powerful and that song wasn't
out yet
but when we hit hands that's what played
in mind the seeds were
sewn in the universe for that song to
eventually exist
at that moment i think the inception is
that
were you like the cool new york version
of yourself at school and like
the like skater
version of yourself at home
yeah so i think uh when i first
went to hotchkiss i was like obsessed
with like east coast culture you know
i was like oh preppy like my brothers
are in finance so i was like oh
i'm going to start wearing lacoste yeah
yeah i just got like one lakasha i'm
going to wear the cost i'm going to wear
all pastel
i'm going to wear boat shoes i'm going
to be you know what i'm going to work on
wall street
and as soon as i got there within like a
month i was uh
first off i didn't understand what a
hedge fund was
um and i do not know that information
now
so yeah yeah i would talk to kids they'd
be like i'd be like what do you want to
do
when you grow up they're like i want to
start a hedge fund
and you know and i was like they're like
what do you want to do i'm like i have
i've always wanted to work at billabong
and then so i just got typecast as like
the california guy
at hotchkiss and so i sort of actually
played that
up a little bit i was like this kind of
like earns me some points
how old were you at this party when you
guys met
7 16 yeah around there
around there and you how long have you
been
partying at that point and how did
partying come into both of your lives
i mean i started actually like partying
when i was like 16.
i mean i got drunk a couple times in
junior high like my parents would leave
and they
like her cabinet was open and my friends
and i would just take a bunch of shots
we actually thought you were like it was
cool to mix alcohol so we do tequila
jack daniels and then
like rum and we just get so sick and
then i finally explained to my parents
how i was drinking and they're like
you're insane
it's not necessary at all but i think
it's 16 is when i started partying but
my parents partied a lot and
so i think i always had like modeling of
partying in front of me like my parents
had a ton of parties so
it was very normal for me so how did you
get into partying
i um yeah so i went to boarding school
i was friends with like the manhattan
kids and so they're like oh you guys you
gotta smoke weed
you gotta start partying so and i was
like yeah yeah this is awesome so we
went to
we could go to new york on some weekends
so we went to new york for a weekend
stay at my buddy ross's house
and we we bought
i bought a tall bottle i'm not sure how
many ounces of corona i was drinking it
on like 82nd and third
and i wasn't really feeling anything and
then i started to lose balance a little
bit and i started laughing like
uncontrollably i'm like oh this is
awesome and i was like 15
at that time and i i really got into
partying i was like this is like the
cool because i was pretty shy so
it was i was like unlocked i felt like
it made me
you know break out a little bit and so i
party in new york a lot and i go back to
california
and party a lot so i was i was pretty
heavy into it like junior year
was raging pretty hard all right so at
this point you guys
meet in high school is it like
do you hit it off and start hanging
around a lot immediately or do you just
start seeing each other around
take take take me through the evolution
of your friendship
i think i just kept running into him at
like cultural events like there'd be a
fight at like the kodo general store
and we would both be there or you know
there would be a bonfire
at san onofre we'd both be there or
everybody would be
everyone ate at the same uh fast food
place oh so jack
so you'd go there and there'd be about
40 cars and his was always one of them
yeah then we just i don't know we were
on the same wavelength yeah
you see somebody enough times yeah you
just keep running
we play volleyball down at creek and
then um
yeah then you just you just become
really tight yeah
yeah he he's kind of like this guy who i
was like
every time i saw him i knew it was just
like automatic laughs you know when you
meet those people you just like can't
stop laughing
that that was for jt and so we
yeah every time we saw each other it was
just like non-stop laughs so that
was and we just continued on and that is
maintained
that's beautiful we're still the one you
still don't wanna
run
[Laughter]
okay um i wanna pull up a photo that you
sent
jt uh so we can talk about i wanna get
more of a vibe of your extended crew
so so
um we're looking at a photo
of just a bunch of bros and wetsuits
um can you talk me through who these
young men
are uh why you're together why the
wetsuits everything
yeah well so first that's my dad in the
top left corner he's already
i know tommy p
um then you got robert greg my younger
brother chris
robbie clinton andrew a bomb and then
that's me all the way on the right
just with just so much face i don't
think
people have that much face
so what are you guys doing here
um we're scuba diving
in uh stewart's cove off paradise island
it's a very nice trip
yeah and is this like would this be a
typical
like crew for you like is this who you
were rolling with at this time
how did this like group come to be i
mean i rolled pretty deep this was just
the guys who were available for the trip
because some guys uh
had like football and whatnot but
no but i'm really close with all these
guys and actually i'm still in group
threads with
uh all of them so we're all still really
tight
is it all the same group thread or
different ones uh there's two different
ones
but mostly mostly overlap there's just
one guy who's not in one because he's
not in our fantasy football league
perfect okay let's roll through the next
photo
that we've got here okay this is another
one that you said
so let's walk us through who these dudes
are and also where are you
there's a pack of marlboro reds on the
table so don't think i don't see that
oh that's a wristband from the bar this
is one of the douchiest nights of my
life uh my friend uh
ross in the lower corner was back from
the naval academy
and uh we all went to the standard hotel
in la
from orange county and uh this is us at
the rooftop bar
and like this is when entourage was
really big so we're all like all right
hey i'm a screenwriter and you're what
are you doing he's like i'm a
sports agent and we're like all right
yeah like like anybody would believe
that looking at us
we all got fake ids that day in in uh in
alvarado park and then we came straight
to this barn and
that was the best haircut i thought i
ever got i got it that day at the
standard
it looks nice there is an entourage vibe
to this whole
photo like you can you can feel the
influence
yeah and then guy all the way on the
left derek he tried to wear like a
skateboarding outfit
and ross yelled at him and said you have
to dress different it really
i could see it really hurt derek but
ross was right
so is this like was this like a special
evening out or would you
do stuff like go to the standard hotel
often no this was very special this was
like a once a year kind of thing where
we were like we're really doing it up
and
having fun i remember everyone fell
asleep we all stayed in the same hotel
room and i stayed up reading everybody's
i didn't have a cell phone at the time
and i just read through everybody's text
messages on their phones while they
slept it's so weird
i can't do that but
okay let's roll through to the next
picture let's talk through this one
who is this what's going on here it's my
very close friend
trevor moylan he's a great guy uh just
got married
congratulations trevor uh this is us
doing a power hour
when we were a little bit over high
school i was probably 19 here
um and we're just having a really we're
both really intense guys
we actually now that he's married we
don't do it as much but we used to
simulate sex every time we were together
we'd hump each other and uh we always
thought we were really conducive that
way
or compatible rather honestly a classic
uh young male friendship yeah basically
yeah he's a good guy this was a good
power hour those are really tough
remind me of the rules of a power hour
you take a shot of beer every minute
okay
right do you remember like did you have
a particular and this
question is for both of you like
favorite
uh party drinking game because my when
we were in high school
we always played kings um
very fun i guess beer pong i got really
into beard eye in college
you know beer die so we have four cups
on each
on each corner of the table and you toss
a die
uh and it gets the the other half and
bounces and someone has to catch it
i've literally never heard of this in my
life but that sounds very fun
it's very fun but i i'm like notoriously
bad at drinking games so
but i loved it because i would just have
to drink more
uh so people on my team will get mad
they'd be like dude
like you gotta be competitive you gotta
you gotta try to win the game i'm like
but
but we're drinking more like i'm see
what the problem is
see i was so anxious in high school that
like i
i would have a performance anxiety with
any of the like beer pong
flip cup related games but kings
you just pick a card and then you do
what's on the card like no skill is
required in that
we can be chatting i would get two like
i didn't have i didn't play any sports
or anything so i couldn't
handle i couldn't handle the competitive
nature
yeah yeah yeah were either of you
in any extra curriculars or anything
like that at your school
uh i played water polo and i swam
uh i didn't really enjoy it um
what else did i do i tried to do acting
but i was like
i just like um i was too shy
i was too shy to stick with it and so i
i always had this desire to do it but
then like i would get into an acting
class i'd be like oh no no i can't i
can't
i can't do it totally totally i was
supposed to be danny zuko
in greece and i went to the were you and
i went to the first dance rehearsal and
i was just too embarrassed i was like a
kid and i love to dance but i just
couldn't
yeah oh my god that's that's so
interesting to me
so wait you auditioned for the part you
got all the way to getting it and then
you were like i'm not gonna dance yeah
it was kind of informal they were just
like hey if you want to like do this
like because we had such a small school
they were like oh
if you want to do this you can do this
and i was like yeah i'm down and i was
like reading the script i was like this
is fun
but i was like also worried about like
having to be romantic with someone on
stage that felt very
vulnerable to me so that's a lot for
your first time to have to do
like grease lightning it's a bit it's a
large role
yeah i would have done a terrible job
the kid who played it instead was like
really
a talented theater man so he did a good
job
what changed between you feeling so
nervous to perform in any capacity then
and the stuff you put out now is it just
the difference of like being yourselves
more
um i think i think for me honestly it
was my
dad's approval he's like you should go
do that and then i just sort of like
was the the shyness and like the walls i
had to break through i just like
kept pounding at them you know until i
broke through and
i just worked at it because i feel like
to to like
do the stuff that you guys do and to
make the videos you make like
i i as someone who was
intensely involved in theater literally
weeping daily over the theater program
at my high school
like yeah i would be so nervous to go
give a speech at like a city council
maybe it's like the uh perceived danger
factor i don't know what it
like there's it's
so i'm allowed to be dumb at the city
council but i don't know if i could i
couldn't play danny zuko dumb
right danny zuko is famously a very
smart boy yeah he's a sharp guy yeah
by his intelligence
[Laughter]
um oh also sorry about it
for the council it was the first one i
was talking about paul walker
and so i think i was like oh i'm talking
about my passion
you know yes and i was like oh that was
fun and so
that that sort of was like kept me going
you know i just talked about things i
love
were you like for both of you did you
get into like much trouble in
high school were you like prank puller
class clowns type at all types at all
i uh in the dorms i would prank people a
lot like i would i'll put like a vacuum
in their room and turn it on while
they're sleeping and
all kinds of like wait one time i made
our buddy george
chug six liters of soda
and he throw up everywhere
uh but but i was like partying so much
and the
the school i went to is like a zero
chance policy so
you know if you get caught with drugs or
alcohol once and like we would like
drink in the showers it was really weird
uh just so we won't get caught you know
we'd have like fader aids and
just showering like this i mean that is
genius
yeah it's like kind of a genius plan
yeah
we're like we're bathing i don't know
what you're talking about what prompted
you to go to
a boarding school like was that your
parents decision or were you like i want
to do this
uh it was it was my my family like all
my siblings i'm the youngest of five
and i have two younger half sisters uh
and my
all my siblings went before me so i
always kind of grew up knowing i would
go
um but i i yeah i almost got kicked out
my junior year because like my my
like mentor teacher whatever was like
you know there's rumors going around of
you like
being hammered moon walking through the
main building
you gotta shut it down i was like all
right all right for sure
cool cool yeah yeah yeah yeah so at the
school since you had like five brothers
and sisters come before you
were you always dealing with like their
reputations too
uh so i older brother's two years older
than me so
yeah and he's a beast you know he he
like
i was i was kind of small and short and
he was already very well developed and
very hairy
i remember when he showed me his pieces
that like almost
almost fainted i was like oh my god
i was like i was like what the [ __ ] is
that
and he's like it's normal i was like all
right
yeah no definitely it's normal 100
that's what i have as well
yeah hello
everyone today's episode of the roast of
your teenage self
podcast is brought to you
by trivia star if i were to ask you to
name a member of
the spice girls or new kids on the block
could you answer in under 15 seconds if
the answer is yes
then you need to play trivia star
trivia star is a free mobile quiz game
that's entertaining and
challenging you can choose categories
like music sports
movies tv animals celebrities and over
60 others to choose from so there's
always more trivia to explore
if you choose the correct answer for
multiple choices and beat the clock
you move on to the next level but the
questions
get harder over time so if you get stuck
don't worry because you can use coins
and gems to get a hint
and move on to the next level it's like
you know when you would have a teacher
who would
allow you to like get some hints to
answers on quizzes or whatever that was
always a cool teacher trivia star
is basically your cool teacher and
trivia star has
over 2 000 five star reviews in the
apple store so join them today
and see if you are smart enough
to win right now trivia star is offering
you
2500 coins and 500 gems when you
download
and play just go to the apple or google
store and search
trivia star again search trivia star and
enjoy
2500 coins and 500 gems
download trivia star for free today
breaking up with your old wireless
provider just got a whole lot easier
thanks to mint mobile they were the
first company
to sell premium wireless services online
only and now mint mobile is introducing
their unlimited data plan for just
30 bucks let that sink in
an unlimited plan
for 30 bucks how much is your soon to be
x wireless provider charging you
okay probably a lot more than that
so for people who hate their phone bill
and are ready to cut ties with big
wireless mint mobile is offering their
premium
unlimited plan for you guessed it
just 30 bucks a month by going online
only and eliminating the traditional
cost of retail mint mobile passes
significant
savings on to you so for those of you
who are like 30 bucks that doesn't make
sense to me how does that happen
this is how it happens and all plans
come with unlimited talks and text plus
high-speed data delivered on the
nation's largest
5g network we love that 5g here
use your own phone with any mint mobile
plan and keep your same phone number
along with all your existing contacts so
you don't have to do that awkward thing
where someone texts you something nice
because they saw that like you were
looking hot on instagram
and then you don't actually know their
phone number and it becomes awkward
spare yourself that and if you're not
100 satisfied mint mobile has you
covered with their seven day
money back guarantee so break up with
big wireless and switch
to mint mobile's premium unlimited data
plan
for 30 bucks a month to get your new
wireless plan for just 30 bucks a month
and get the plan shipped to your door
free
go to mint mobile.com teen
self that's mint mobile dot com slash
teen self cut your unlimited wireless
build to
30 bucks a month at mint mobile.com
team south throw some betting on a bunch
of different mattresses and sure
they all look alike the same goes for
pillows but peel away the layers
and look at what's inside and you'll see
that they all aren't created equal oh no
that's what makes every purple pillow
and mattress unlike
anything you've ever slept on
the purple grid sets the purple mattress
apart from every other mattress and its
patented comfort technology instantly
adapts to your body's natural shape and
sleep style
with over 1800 open air channels
designed to neutralize body heat
purple provides a cooling effect other
mattresses
can't replicate and this cutting edge
technology doesn't stop with the
mattresses
every purple pillow is engineered with
the grid for total
head and neck support and absolute
airflow
so you're always on the cool side of the
pillow
purple's proprietary technology has been
innovating comfort for over 15 years
and now here we have come again to be
part of the ad
where i talk about how i sweat in my
sleep
and the purple pillow helped me to not
wake up
in a pool of nasty wetness every day
it's everyone's favorite part of the
podcast when they imagine
me and my fiance in our sweaty
nasty bed but not anymore thanks to
purple
experience the purple grid and you'll
sleep like never before
go to purple.com teen self
10 and use the promo code teen self
10 that's teen self and then
the number 10 for a limited time offer
and you'll get 10
off orders of 200 or more
that's purple.com teen self 10 promo
code teen
self 10 for 10 off any order of 200
or more terms apply
and so like when i went to high school
like my brother everyone's like oh your
brother mark he's such a beast like he
lifts so many weights i was like oh yeah
yeah for sure so
i guess it's kind of living up to that
was like a
uh something i dealt with to an extent
but i tried to differentiate myself a
little bit
now jt you went to two different schools
yeah
santa margarita catholic high school and
then jay sarah catholic high school
and okay so you already told me before
we started recording but tell us about
the
the why you had to move from one high
school to the other
yeah well i i so i got kicked out of
santa margarita after my sophomore year
because i just
had so many i would get so many
detentions and then i wouldn't go to my
detentions
and so they would compile and i missed
37 detentions my sophomore year
i just i just could not do anything that
i was supposed to
and i was really loud in class and i had
like a 1.0 gpa and i did no
extracurricular so
i kind of i wasn't giving him a lot of
reason to keep me but i had a really
good time
it was fun i mean honestly it's it
sounds like you brought a lot to the
school culture
uh and to the environment so i guess
that goes back to my other question
like do you feel like you had like a
class clown
reputation there were you like a lovable
rascal who ultimately did have to be
expelled or
like a villain i think i was a little
bit of both if i'm being honest i think
i was mostly lovable i never did
anything like criminal but i could be
like so intense that i could be like
kind of like
too intense like bullying or get into
like fights and stuff like that
it was just i mean the truth is i was
probably just bipolar and
do you have 80d and i was like i don't
think so and then uh but i just had so
much energy and i was just like uh
i don't know i was just running around
out of control like i just do
i had to do like a crazy thing every
week right i felt
not like myself do you remember some of
the things that earned you
uh i guess i mean obviously you were
getting a lot of it detentions but
uh if you had if you do have any
highlights of the things that earned you
detentions
yeah i like streaked for like a week
straight after school but like on the
public streets
so i thought i wouldn't be able to get
in trouble at school but it's a private
school they don't have they have
you absolutely can get in trouble in
school
yeah and then i was like i was like you
can't suspend me i was like i was
streaking on antonio
you're like you've got to i can suspend
you and it was like
it was in your carpool and i was like
all right whatever fine and then
that was a good one and then what was
some other good ones i got i mean i just
i threw like a huge house party
that got a lot of like no right
like teachers were coming up to me like
the day before and they're like you have
to shut this down
and i was like the wheels are already in
motion too many people are coming
there's nothing i can do to stop and i
just have to like
yeah it's not shut down a ball it's just
bigger than all of us
exactly and then i ended up getting a
saturday school for that but that was
like
i don't know yeah those were like the
the highlight ones
the biggest like i'd check out a book
from the library and never return it
and then at some point they just end up
suspending you if you keep it long
enough
chad let's go through some of your
photos that you sent
um so that we can round out the pictures
so let's talk about who who is this uh
it's you and a young woman you appear to
be at like a picnic
outdoors what's going on here you're
vibing yeah you guys are
that yeah yeah that's actually my friend
stephanie and we're at the oddball
comedy festival and i'm pretty i'm
pretty sure i was blacked out at this
point
because i missed the train home so i
like came to
i was like i was like it was like in the
middle of irvine i was like
where do i go and so i like took this
like huge
this super long uber back um
you have a good like spiky toss old hair
going i know i think i was really trying
to like
i was going for like a short hair look i
was like yeah i'm gonna give this a shot
and
style it up but i'm not a big fan right
now
but it was it was a look at the time it
was a look at the time
yeah the shades too and this is a friend
not a girlfriend yeah it's a friend are
you
dating much at this time like did you
start dating in high school
um kind of i was kind of a late bloomer
i i had a girlfriend
for like a month i was kind of like in
this i had a girlfriend for like a month
and you know uh but
not much i think it was the shyness i
was just kind of like
i was just cruising were you a big
unrequited crush
person uh
yeah i think so yeah yeah i'd say so
yeah i'm keeping myself and in my mind
i'm like well if i just like stand
in there with you know within five feet
of them
they'll wanna they'll know that i want
to date them you know
surely she'll look over here eventually
yeah but i just
i i just said they look over i'm just
like flex people
i'll give i'll let them know like oh
this guy's
this guy wants a relationship he's so
charming
what about you did you were you dating
in high school were you
unrequited crushing i was like
just i couldn't i couldn't handle being
intimate with another person so i was
like a i was a virgin til i was 24. so
it took it took me a while to
to get over it but uh or to feel
comfortable enough with myself to
to do that with somebody but but on
trips like i'd always do better on like
vacations
like because i didn't i i felt like i
had too big of like a
like a can around my tail at home and i
was like if i hook up with someone and
i'm bad at it everyone's going to find
out
and then they're going to be like
they're like oh that guy who dances on
tables and axel badass
he's actually just doing that because he
like sucks at hooking up so i was like
i was very like protective over that
part of myself and i just looked
horrendous
[Laughter]
know that getting a vacation like a
vacation
paramour is such a huge thing and me
it's so funny i was just um i was just
down at the beach and my friends and i
were talking about this because
i my family we would go to wildwood new
jersey over the summer
and my friend megan would come with me
and we had a move
to get our like to attract boys on the
boardwalk
we would we would keep an eye out for
two like
hot topic-y looking guys around our age
you know they've got like the pants
that have the we knew who our target
demo
was and then we would go over by them on
the boardwalk and we would ask them
if they wanted to ride the tilt-a-whirl
with us because you're like it's more
fun with more
people oh smart yeah and we did this
a lot you guys had a good good routine
genuinely predatory behavior
it was funny too sometimes you go on a
vacation you run into someone from home
at the vacation and then you would hook
up and then you'd come back to the real
world
and you're like i don't know what we are
at this point now yes
uh i also i don't know if you guys ever
had the experience of
having a person that you talked to only
online
and in school you did not oh yeah
i never had that that's interesting yeah
i had many like
like we would get each other's screen
names and truly chat for hours
online and then at school you say
nothing to each other
yeah i had that i had that for sure i
remember i would
there's one girl in like middle school
where i uh out on instant messenger i
had like a huge crush on her i would
like message her i'd be like what's up
and then like i'd see her at school and
she'd like come near me and just like
i was sort of like um uh vogel and and
super bad you know when he turns right
around
i would do that basically
run away and then my brother dated her
oh my god the big brother with the pubes
the pew yeah puke the pube man
pube brother dated i was like you're
dating those pews no
[Laughter]
oh no that's so sad okay i
i was over i i did some swimming laps
and i was over it
okay let's run through the last of your
photos and then we'll wrap it up here i
think you had
okay who who are who's here where are we
you guys look like you're in a bar
yeah that's my buddy nick aka uh
ass man that's because we're that's
cause they're seinfeld fans
uh yeah that's just uh
that's just us at a bar yeah we got into
a bar
i was rocking a flannel short hair again
uh i was trying to go with some facial
hair there and we were just bonding hard
he's good he's a great guy there's not a
lot of context behind it
so were you able you were able to get
into bars like starting pretty early
uh yeah in new york we were
um we were just like we would go like
you know do like sake bombs and stuff
and i can't remember which bar this was
but uh
i had my brother's um i got a fake id
and it kind of worked you know i would
kind of just like slip in
i look so young though you know like i
look like i'm like 14 there
yeah you you do look like a baby yeah
so you know bouncers would just look at
me to be like are you
[ __ ] serious like dude i just want to
rage
please let me in and sometimes they're
like okay yeah
yeah all right i think you have one more
photo
let's see oh yeah
this one you definitely appear to be
raging
yeah are you the dj
that's me a graduation night uh
there was another dj actually dj
aesthetic
[Laughter]
and he is he's crushing the tables but
you know i i
i was just try i tried djing for like a
song i was more kind of making fun of
him actually i think
uh i'm sure he loved that that's where
the face comes in yeah
uh he's my buddy though so i was just
like
i was just turning the tables but but
i think i mean i don't i don't want to
be braggy here but i'm pretty sure i did
start the party so
um yeah and this was so was this like
the big
graduation party yeah the big graduation
party it was
we had kind of a cool graduation thing
where we like we partied for like a
weekend when we would go to different
people's houses and like camp out
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah
dj aesthetic was just crushing it
did either of you guys have beach week
because my school a lot of people did
beach week where everyone
would go to the beach for a week but my
crew like we ultimately couldn't get it
together to go
um i don't think i ever did beach week
we'd go to cabo sometimes in high school
yeah what do you do in cabo and hi well
i guess you can do whatever you want in
cabo in high school you have to have a
fake id but you'd like
go down there with a couple friends and
just try to like
get drunk at the beach then meet girls
at night at a club or something like
that
yeah vacation girlfriends i'd like el
squid rope yeah
all right okay i think that this brings
us to the end so i always end with
one final question uh you guys can take
turns answering it
if you could talk to your high school
self today
what would you tell them i do this in
therapy all the time
um this is like a exercise we do um
i'd say relax it's all good
yeah and cut your hair
i would say be yourself
nice yeah just be yourself
very nice beautiful what else would i
tell them
i'd say stop putting like trying to
cover your acne it's making the acne
worse
that's actually that's actually huge yes
yeah
because i was putting makeup on every
day and then you get you get caught by
people wearing makeup and then it's like
it's just like
it's just easier just to let it be there
yeah and that's real confidence if you
can own your acne that's like
real confidence yes yeah i would tell my
teenage self to stop using maybelline
dream matte mousse foundation because
it's not
good for your skin yeah
uh all right guys well it was so awesome
to have you
on the pod uh you were so funny and
uh for everyone listening at home this
has been the roast of your teenage sales
podcast
you